[Musique]
moi ce soir j'avais envie de vous parler
de la chance
il y a Louis Pasteur qui disait la
chance ne sourit qu'aux esprits bien
préparés et c'est une phrase qui a
toujours raisonnée en moi qui m'a
toujours interpellé et j'ai envie de la
décortiquer avec vous ce soir pour
essayer de mettre toutes les chances de
votre côté pour pas passer à côté de
votre chance j'ai eu 10 minutes à la
faire cette phrase
alors c'est quoi la chance quand on est
petit on grandit et la carte chance moi
mon premier souvenir c'est cette carte
chance du Monopoly et c'est soit tu
passes par pas du tout par la case
départ et tu prends 0 € et tu vas
directement en prison soit tu prends un
million d'euros et parce que tu es ronde
te rapporte quelque chose donc cette
chance le côté aléatoire de cette chance
de cette chance ça me dérange et c'est
ça ce soir que j'essaye que je vais
essayer de vous expliquer c'est que la
chance ça se provoque la chance ça se
prépare et pour éviter que mon erreur
d'avoir passé à côté d'une chance d'être
face à une chance je voulais vous faire
ce petit toc ce soir ce soir là sur mon
frigo j'ai Céline Dion qui me dit pour
Alma bonne chance pour l'Eurovision
merci beaucoup mais la chance bah rien à
voir là bas le travail on en parlera
plus tard mais la chance c'est quelque
chose qui me dépasse évidemment on se
souhaite tous bonne chance en ce moment
on est tous des adultes et on aime aussi
s'appuyer sur la chance pour se
justifier de nos échecs j'ai raté mon
train j'ai pas de chance à Nantes partie
trop tard la copine m'a quitté j'ai pas
de chance non tu as dû faire un truc qui
marche pas la chance c'est nous qui la
provoquons ce n'est que les conséquences
de ce que l'on de nos actions
pour vous éviter de faire les mêmes
erreurs que moi je vous racontais mon
histoire moi je j'ai voulu faire de la
musique depuis que je suis toute petite
depuis que je suis née je fais du piano
mes parents m'ont laissé m'ont donné des
cours de piano de cours de solfège donc
j'ai été baignée là dedans toute toute
mon enfance
et il arrive ce moment fatidique ou à 18
ans il faut prendre la décision de sa
vie c'est à dire choisir ce qu'on va
faire dans quel chemin on va
s'engouffrer qu'elle voit on va suivre à
18 ans on est des bébés on sait rien de
la vie donc moi personnellement je me
suis appuyé sur mes parents parce que
pourquoi
on n'est pas libre on n'est pas émancipé
encore à cet âge-là et dans la société
dans laquelle on vit dans la société
dans le monde dans lequel j'ai grandi
moi en faisait une école de commerce
rien d'autre on faisait voir si pardon
il y avait aussi école d'ingénieur mais
alors la musique c'était pour les
saltimbanques c'était un stable ça
gagnait pas d'argent ils avaient pas
tout à fait tort mais c'était quelque
chose pour moi qui me passionnait et
j'avais vraiment envie de suivre cette
voie
j'allais dire on m'en a empêché mais non
je me suis empêché
d'aller prendre cette direction
et donc j'ai suivi ce que papa et maman
m'ont dit que je remercie d'ailleurs au
passage mais
j'ai passé cinq ans à l'ISF est une
merveilleuse école de commerce
évidemment j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses donc je finis l'islg et là je dis
mes parents merci beaucoup c'est super
mais maintenant je vais faire de la
musique donc je viens à Paris pour
essayer de vivre de mon de mon rêve de
ma passion et on commence à faire des
rencontres on se rend compte surtout que
la musique c'est beaucoup de temps et là
je me dis j'ai perdu 50 ma vie à prendre
des statistiques
et si je vous parle de ça ce soir c'est
parce que j'ai pas envie de vous
reproduisiez
les mêmes c'est pas vraiment des erreurs
mais de plier de pas s'écouter de pas
être ancré au sol de pas se connaître
donc ensuite je signe un super contrat
dans une grande maison de disque au bout
de un an et demi donc je suis ravie je
vis de mon rêve ça y est je suis arrivée
dans une maison disque c'est génial je
suis très fière je suis ravie sauf que
après ça c'est là que le travail
commence et moi je pensais que j'étais
arrivé j'avais 23 ans j'étais là ou à
trop bien je rencontrais dans une grande
maison de disque c'est bon je suis
chanteuse j'ai la reconnaissance
pas du tout mais on disque ça ne sert à
rien c'est vous qui servez c'est le
public le zones
ça ne sert à rien il faut me tuer
donc je suis dans cette maison disque et
au bout de deux ans on sort enfin une
première chanson moi pendant deux ans je
fais quoi j'attends je suis patiente
j'attends que mon tour arrive je suis
passive
et
du coup je m'excite un peu et j'appelle
une manadeuse il faut qu'on m'aide parce
que là vraiment il se passe rien et la
manageuse me dit ok très bien je vais te
prendre sous mon aile et je vais te
faire faire l'Eurovision
pour ceux qui connaissent pas je pense
la plupart de là c'est un concours de
chant international qui est regardé par
180 millions de téléspectateurs
180 millions de téléspectateurs et moi
on va pas le matin on me dit bon c'est
bon tu vas faire l'Eurovision les gars
j'ai même pas fait un seul concert de ma
vie rien et vous allez me mettre sur
cette scène devant 180 millions dans
cette robe avec des talons camos
c'est là où commence ce périple
intéressant
où je suis juste spectatrice de mon
propre spectacle
je suis marionnette les équipes
s'étendent des gens me disent quoi faire
quoi quoi porter quoi dire comment
comment m'exprimer quoi chanter la
chanson que j'ai chanté c'était pas une
de mes chansons
et je me suis laissée faire parce que
parce que
je sais pas
je sais pas pourquoi je me suis laissé
faire mais j'aimerais bien que ce speech
vous permettent de pas vous laisser
faire
oh là là
je vous ai concocté cette petite
pyramide parce qu'à la fin de
l'Eurovision donc quand je suis rentré
de cette expérience incroyable j'ai eu
pas mal d'interview et il y a quelqu'un
qui m'a dit c'est rien les étoiles
devaient pas être alignées
sûrement alors du coup je me suis
demandé comment je fais pour aligner mes
étoiles parce que
c'est hyper important d'avoir des
étoiles alignées tout le monde en parle
tous les gens qui ont du succès tous les
gens qu'on entend oui ben un jour les
étoiles se sont alignées et ça a
fonctionné oui mais c'est pas si facile
que ça alors j'ai essayé de réfléchir et
de vous faire cette magnifique pyramide
donc pour moi tout part d'ici
tout part de la connaissance de soi de
l'émancipation de tout ce qu'on vous
apprend de vos parents de vos amis de là
où de la religion dans laquelle vous
avez été élevé dans même le sexe dans
lequel vous avez été élevé vous pouvez
choisir de tout il faut absolument que
vous preniez le temps que vous vous
instruisiez que vous alliez titiller
cette curiosité d'apprendre des autres
de il y a pas qu'un seul monde il y a
pas qu'un seul milieu social et il y a
pas qu'une seule possibilité et il y a
pas qu'un seul chemin et ça
c'est un travail qui est cyclique on se
enfin j'espère je vous souhaite à tout
le monde de vous une fois vous
rencontrez vous connaître pour toute
votre vie mais on évolue on change donc
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut faire
tout le temps
cette connaissance de soi elle nous
apporte une liberté qui nous est unique
et qui permet
d'aller essayer de choper sa chance
sachant la deuxième
surcouche de la pyramide c'est la
confiance par exemple on est dans un
bateau il y a deux capitaines il y en a
un qui vous dit bah viens sur mon bateau
je suis pas sûr il va couler peut-être
mais c'est pas grave viens tu as pas
envie d'y aller alors que l'autre il est
là
on est évidemment attiré donc la
confiance attire les gens autour de vous
la confiance que vous ayez que vous avez
en vous et en votre projet elle attire
une team elle attire d'autres personnes
qui vont vous aider à faire fleurir ce
projet
un truc sur la confiance parce que si
vous avez le capitaine du Titanic et on
a trop de confiance ça marche pas faut
trouver ce petit équilibre
le troisième
c'est le travail
le travail
péjoratif le travail moi j'ai fait de la
musique parce que j'aimais pas
travailler
en fait le travail c'est une chance de
pouvoir travailler de pouvoir se fixer
un véritable objectif
de pouvoir nourrir son projet avec tous
tout ce travail et toutes ces recherches
pour venir consolider vraiment votre
projet
et la dernière pour moi c'est cette
chance
la chance elle arrive c'est vraiment la
dernière petite chose qui arrive comme
une cerise sur le gâteau parce que quand
vous aurez vous serez en face de cette
chance vous serez
l'identifier vous serez l'attraper et ça
vous créera cet alignement des étoiles
normalement
pour vous amener à votre réussite
j'adore cette phrase
la vie c'est comme une boîte de chocolat
on sait jamais sur quoi on va tomber
moi tout ce que je peux vous dire
là-dessus c'est que
il faut pas avoir peur de mettre sa main
dans la boîte de chocolat parce qu'au
pire quoi on en prend il est pas très
bon c'est pas grave
statistiquement on va prendre une boîte
de chocolat qui a dit chocolat il va y
en avoir 7 qui sont délicieux trois qui
sont pas bons
bon
les personnes qui vont accéder les
personnes qui vont oser les personnes
qui vont pousser pour aller chercher ce
quatrième morceau de chocolat
je vous souhaite d'être celle-là
[Musique]